hey youtubers we need to talk about the
show's biggest problem and it has
nothing to do with White Walkers of the
night King just careful for spoilers for
everything that's happened so far
there's a new round of the HBO now
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so everybody knows about the night
king the White Walkers the army of the
Dead the add to the place Dallas is even
quoted as saying that there are a
hundred thousand strong meaning that
even if everyone put aside their
differences in the south they still
wouldn't match their numbers the reason
why that's not a big problem is is
because the trailer has already spelled
out what the plan is Jon Snow narrates a
lot about how they need to put their
differences aside
Davos threatens them all with the idea
of a skeleton sitting on the Iron Throne
everybody's going to be dead it won't
matter so the biggest problem of Season
seven isn't the army of the Dead is
actually people that throw wrenches into
the plan to fight the army of the Dead
which it sounds like Santa is going to
do because they did interviews with all
the actors and there's a really
interesting one with Kit Harington and
one with Littlefinger that sort of spell
out how Santa is going to be a problem
with Jon Snow Kit Harington says and I
quote there's a definite tension between
them right from the first scene there
are the same problems she questions his
decisions in command he doesn't listen
to her but as far as where that goes or
takes them or how dark it can get we'll
see it gets past sibling squabbling it
gets into two people power struggling so
that already sounds really ominous but
I'll read the Littlefinger quote - then
we'll analyze what they're talking about
the actor that plays a Littlefinger says
I finished last season on a promising
note by laying my cards on the table at
least - Sansa I was sowing seeds of
doubt about Jon Snow throughout my
appearances in season six in yeah that
will continue in season seven it's
pretty obvious that my game is there but
at the same time my character is
becoming quite aware that Sansa is
becoming as bright as me in just as
weary of my manipulations of her they're
on to each other they use each other
they enjoy each other and they keep a
lot from each other there are all kinds
of mix things going on with Littlefinger
in his relationship with Sansa so
watching her grow in stature is quite
enjoyable
so that actually sounds pretty dangerous
because it sounds like she's much more
complete
with little finger than what we thought
before you've seen a lot of images of
them on set there's a picture of her
giving him the side eye here so he's
weaving his plans while at the same time
being aware that she's watching him
knowing that she's being manipulated so
there are a lot of narrative reasons why
Sansa is one of the biggest problems of
season 7 up in the north because Jon
Snow all he cares about is fighting the
army of the Dead in getting everybody to
unite but that can't happen when people
within your own camp or backstabbing you
because like salsa said during season
six when they were marshalling the army
to try and fight the Bolton's people
will rally to the stark name the North
remembers but Jon Snow does not have the
stark name I do I'm not sure she
believed that jon is capable of running
Winterfell amendment I think she thinks
he doesn't have the intellect the
knowledge the experience this she I
think you know he has wonderful morals
and that that kind of like stark morals
you know inevitably they'll make the
right decisions but all the good
decisions but whether it's going to
benefit any more lose another story so
the other big reason why thoughts on her
storyline are a big problem or because
of the challenges of adapting the books
TV you have to cut a lot of things out
you have to focus on characters that you
might not spend as much time with in the
books like Cersei got a big upgrade from
book Cersei Sansa has also had a giant
upgrade from book Santa in the amount of
time the story focuses on her when kid
Harrington talks about them not
communicating with each other
him not consulting her about decisions
he's not a bad commander but he doesn't
have as much experience of someone who
fought in the war of the five kings or
even Robert's rebellion Samwell Tarly
'he's father is a good example of one of
the best battle commanders in the realm
he fought for the crown during that
period so kid Harrington talks about the
sibling rivalry lasting all season going
to very dark places
what kind of wrench could saunter throw
into that problem well Littlefinger
wants to support Shaun so they command
the forces of the Vale Littlefinger
could always
hold support but the North largely
seemed like it supported John Snow we
don't care what his last name is that
was what that whole little bear speech
was about but based on all the quotes
that the actors are giving it sounds
like maybe not everybody in the North
was on board with that the North is a
big place
they love the Starks maybe there are
some that are still pure to the stark
name and believe John Snow is a bastard
doesn't have as much right as Santa to
leave so Santa looks like she's learning
the power of forming alliances the power
of politicking like Littlefinger so
there were a couple times during season
six where she showed up how much
knowledge he had of the broader things
that were happening in Westeros that Jon
Snow didn't know about it all she knew
about what the blackfish was doing
because of her proximity to Ramsay she
understood Ramsay better than Jon Snow
did and you can call that willful
ignorance and service of plot but I
actually think it's a good way of
showing how much Jon Snow is like Ned
Stark and that they're very certain of
their beliefs but they don't always have
all the information and they don't
always mistrust people the way they
should
like when Littlefinger told Ned Stark
the first thing you should do is trust
no one don't trust me Jon Snow seems
like he's making some of the same
mistakes as Ned Stark very pure
intentions but not the political
instincts of someone like Littlefinger
who's operating on a much higher level
playing the game all in your mind all
over the place all at once it sounds
like he's speaking to Santa when he's
saying that because he wants to seduce
her to the dark side well at the same
time she's trying to learn everything
she can without being completely
swallowed by Littlefinger's narrative it
in pursuit of that will clash with Jon
Snow continually because she'll start
learning things that he won't know he
won't listen to her it'll sow the seeds
of discord that will prevent everyone
from coming together the way they need
to to fight the army of the Dead but I
think based on the timeline they'll get
there before season 8 but there you see
some of the more practical problems of
adapting the books to the TV show where
in you have to drum up this drama in the
north where it really doesn't need to
exist Jon Snow already defeated the
Bolton's the north is united they're
dealing with the rogue defeated houses
like the car starts in the umbers but
you still have someone like Santa who
says that she doesn't necessarily care
about the Iron Throne but she wants to
be in charge she was
credit so you spend all this time
dealing with that when really their
focus should be on what's going on in
the south with Daenerys and Cersei
Daenerys has this giant flea you think
they'd be talking about that it'll
probably be addressed in the first
couple of episodes depending on how
quickly Ravens are dispatched to
Winterfell further complicating matters
you have brand Stark who has all this
information about Jon Snow's relevant
which is only going to fan Sansa and
Littlefinger flames because even though
technically he would still be a bastard
unless Lyanna stark and rhaegar were
married it would make him a much more
legitimate heir meaning that most people
in the north would completely forget
about Sansa they'd still love her as a
start but if you were on the fence about
this amazing bastard that won this huge
battle got rid of the Bolton's
and found out that he came from the
purest of blood you would back him in a
second throwing up all kinds of
speculation about how Littlefinger and
Santa would react to that so let me know
in the comments
bran reveals the truth of Jon Snow's
origin to everyone if he does how do you
think Sauza and Littlefinger react to
that because Littlefinger is only
focused on the Iron Throne that's the
game he's playing if Jon Snow is a
legitimate heir and he aligns with
Daenerys that's the end for him so there
you see where the big problem lies the
big wrench in the plan them all coming
together if they come together
Littlefinger is done for so the only
hope is in Sansa realizing how bad
Littlefinger is for their grand plan in
putting aside her differences with Jon
Snow so we'll see how long they stretch
that out but I can already sense that
that's going to be one of the biggest
complaints about Season seven is is why
didn't she tell him this like that was
literally one of the questions they
asked a comic-con
why didn't you tell Jon Snow about the
Knights of the Vale chale Jon because
she wanted all the credit and in the
more dramatic moment
going up and it makes really good
television so what's going to happen
next is there'll be more Game of Thrones
this weekend I am expecting another
trailer before the season drops there'll
be a lot of extra special stuff
happening the week before the season
starts leave all your requests for bonus
videos in the comments congratulations
to Brandon Stuart you're the latest
giveaway winner you can click here to
learn all about Ozora hi and you can
click here to learn all about your on
Greyjoy confirming a big theory about
season 7 thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight